[Music]
well
if it makes you feel any better mike
traveling's about to open up and wait
till you hear how
i have a feeling it's gonna not be good
what can we realistically
expect once the immunization process
actually starts
and i'm hearing there's talk about a
vaccine passport what is that
ah ghost uh yes uh thank you for asking
so the
vaccine passport is gonna be a system
we're gonna implement where
uh you're basically not allowed to have
any sort of semblance of a normal life
unless you've had the vaccine
it's going to be proof that you had a
vaccine so it's going to be like
sort of our way of circumventing the
constitution
and forcing you to do something against
your will
but finding a clever way around it by
having
private businesses uh all sign up for
this passport program
yay well you know what susan where do i
sign up
you know what i don't care i host an
internet talk show
um i barely leave my house i'm old i
don't care anymore
and guess what i get 90 of my [ __ ] from
amazon i'll line jeff bezos's pockets
i don't need a passport leave the box at
the [ __ ] door that's fine
i'll live off uber eats and [ __ ]
amazon i'm not getting the shot
yeah so this is this kind of futuristic
idea well we actually have
a requirement to get a certificate of
vaccination before we can do things so
it's a futuristic idea no no no no no no
it's not a futuristic idea
it's an orwellian hellscape
no no did we see other it's this like
future it's like the future's like
flying cars
no it's not it's the movie equilibrium
so like you know how everybody's been
waiting on that game cyberpunk 2077.
this is basically like cyberpunk oh i
like video games yeah so it's do you
like videos
i love video games i'm gonna put this
needle in you that's right do i get a
video
game well no oh we'll get you we'll get
you a pokemon game for switch
fine but that's all you're getting by
the way why do you notice
her this is the only time i've ever seen
anybody like this her teeth
come down but in a rounded fashion
i've never seen that before they
actually curve
perfectly round right into my wrong
hands
this is the most bizarre doll's teeth
it's very hot right
kind of futuristic idea will we actually
have
a requirement to get a certificate of
vaccination before we can do things so
as dr gupto was talking about it's going
to be a while before most of us can get
a vaccine it's going to be the most
high-risk groups at the beginning
because of limited supply
and then folks like dr fauci are talking
about do you see how she just blew right
through that
so it's good i'm hoping she comes back
to it because i kind of feel like that
that's the biggest
issue with everything they're talking
about she's not going to come back to it
because this is how they operate
they slip it in so they can say they
told you
and then they go and they add a bunch of
stuff so you go
yeah okay that was great you talked for
like four minutes but can you go back to
the part where you said
a passport where we're not going to be
allowed to go do normal things
that's the important thing because you
said that but then you blew past and
started talking about some other things
that's what the media always does
they're just like yeah hey listen
uh we're doing great over in afghanistan
uh we've already begun the process of
clearing rubble from manhattan and we're
going to start the rebuilding process
and america is going to come back
stronger than ever
and we've also authorized the nsa to
wiretap
private citizens phone calls without a
warrant and also
soon we're going to have the engineers
come out we're going to be redesigning
the new york city skyline it's going to
be better
that's awesome oh green energy what did
you say before that though
uh well we'll get to that the buildings
are going to be built uh
to be a bit more airplane proof in this
couple no but no but the thing before
though you said something about the
nsa back better what about you know why
it's happening
anyway ladies and gentlemen uh enjoy the
free drinks
and uh you guys have a great day take
care wear a mask
but that's what they do and then you go
uh wait i really would like to revisit
the thing you just said about the
warrantless
wiretaps what was that about can you
explain that to me we're going to start
wiretapping rival political campaigns
anyway thanks folks have a great day
but don't worry we're going to also
wired to have our own political campaign
we've already have everybody
everyone's wiretapped yay it's safer
for everybody really being able to get
access and so then what does life start
to look like
i don't know what does it look like i
hate this woman well let's see what life
starts to look like i
know because i want to see these people
are going to be the ones that rep
these people represent the dystopia
these people are the ones that are going
to be like
hey who wants to get a needle in their
arms so they're allowed to go to busch
gardens again
yay you're going to be like this is who
wants to be allowed to engage in
interstate travel
unrestricted do you have your passport
yay
it's they get these little [ __ ]
upbeat little bunny looking [ __ ]
bunny looking [ __ ] that's what she
looks like she looks like a bunny she
really does
she looks like the female rabbit from
space jam
so then what does life start to look
like do we have to have
that certificate of vaccinations
do we have to have a certificate of
vaccination that certificate of
vaccination before getting on a cruise
ship or getting on a plane for example
experts i've talked with say that is a
possibility but what about like going to
concerts or going to a restaurant would
you need a certificate of vaccination to
do that that
might be less likely but companies like
ticketmaster are already thinking about
why is she so if it do you know you know
if i got this information in a real
world you know how i would be acting
not like this like you know they my
friend i'd be like
god [ __ ] guys this is the most important
thing you're gonna hear today
they're going to have to stick medicine
in you for you to fly and be on cruise
ships
we can't allow this instead she's like
experts i'm talking about or like saying
i'm like you should be everybody should
be
[ __ ] outraged and going are you
[ __ ]
kidding me you're gonna let the the gun
we have to let the government stick a
needle in our arm before i go on a
cruise or go
on an airplane are you [ __ ] nuts yeah
no you're right though if they did like
if i had to break that news to people
they'd be like
we're going to go live to mike shiley
now he's got some news and it would just
they would just
the camera would hit me and it would be
this
they're gonna just start screaming and
grabbing people and going
they'd have to come and wrap you up in a
straight jacket and take you out of
there
you it would be like charlie day for um
remember it's always sunny when he's
doing the pepe it would be the pepe
silvia thing
you would just have a board and you'd be
rambling and screaming and they'd go
like what is wrong with
but she's like yay needles forests yay
nation to do that that might be less
likely but companies like ticketmaster
are already thinking about
ideas like that could they have a
technology for example to link your
concert ticket to
proof that you've been vaccinated so
these are the kinds of things that are
getting talked about
none of it is set in stone yet but
experts are saying we should think about
these things
what life is going to be like with
vaccines and they are warning that even
as more of us get vaccinated we're still
going to have to wear masks and socially
distance for a lot of next year
so then what's the point
so you have to get a vaccine but your
life also doesn't get to go back to
normal
yeah isn't it so what's what's the point
i don't understand what the point is
i mean i don't know
yeah i know i know no one knows there's
no there's
literally nothing about this that's good
there's not even really anything like
there's really
just no way to spin this positively like
if i worked for like the press corps for
these people i'd be like i don't know
what you want me to go out there and
tell these people
you've been talking meg with a lot of
experts have you talked to anybody about
you know will we able be
will we be able to choose which vaccine
we get that's been a big question
yeah so at the beginning probably not
just because supply is going to be so
limited it's going to be take what you
can get whenever you can get it
but if this turns into a vaccine we have
to hate her every year like the flu shot
if this turns into a vaccine listen to
this that we have to take every like the
flu shot
you don't have to take the flu shot
every year
you can choose to never had one but no
but
but but the wording of that is like you
have to take every
so it's this isn't are they already
missed what you said man they already
slipped these things in they're already
preparing you for it this is going to be
one and done
this is going to be every year now
you're going to have to get a vaccine
alcovet vaccine to live your life i i'm
this whole thing is creepy they they
really need to find a woman who's less
creepy to tell us this
like she's too happy she's too fake
smile like this is a woman who
has never been happier entire life this
is a woman who
read books on how to look happy and how
to succeed by being
you know smiley and stuff but this broad
is there's nothing going on in those
eyes
look at the eyes but if this turns into
a vaccine we have to take
every year like the flu shot or maybe
every couple years by then there will
probably be enough supply that like the
flu shot
there will be different options we can
choose from for the flu shot there's a
high dose version for people over 65
there's a nasal spray
there are different options and you can
actually call your pharmacy and make
sure they've got the one you want before
you go in so
down the line we could see that for
coveted vaccines but at the beginning
it's going to be
take what you can get hey dr gupta there
was a kind of a
what i thought was kind of a disturbing
poll from the american association of
nurses revealing that
only 36 percent said hey i got a
disturbing pole for you right
here is it your penis
was my yeah it was my dick cool
it's kind of a disturbing poll from the
american association of nurses revealing
that
only 36 percent said that they would get
vaccinated and i got to
imagine that extends out into the
general population as
and as we've heard it's only 36 percent
of
nurses saying they're gonna get back so
right there that shows you i love how he
said but you know what it's
disturbing it's disturbing you won't
take this untested drug
it's disturbing to me no like it no to
me it's just
you know what's disturbing to me what's
disturbing to me was what did they say
36 said they won't they won't take it so
what's disturbing to me is that
64 said sure i'll take it that's what's
disturbing to me is how many people are
going
what's in it i don't even care fine just
shoot it in me that's disturbing it
disturbing to me is
sure shoot me up government that's
[ __ ]
crazy how many people are like okay with
that
not the vaccine it's vaccinations is is
that gonna be a problem going forward
well i'm turning my head he looks like a
confused dog
he really does he looks like a dog when
you talk to a dog when you speak
complete sentences to a dog listen i'm
gonna go to wendy's
okay and i'm gonna go to walmart but
i'll be back in about an hour
you know i suspect that once we have
the data actually publicly available
once
this advisory group external experts
levies their decisions and says that the
vaccines are effective
very effective in some cases and broadly
safe
that that that number is going to change
you're going to see broader adoption i
know all of us
uh in healthcare clinicians public
health experts to decide
we want a message on the data and say
the data is it's like
mac's head room over here it really is
the that's a weird glitch
because it usually doesn't glitch like
that that's an odd glitch yeah
so when you have all the data but how
many things like you said how many p
how many companies are being sued now
that there was data that everything was
safe
it happens all the time when they say
this is safe this is safe does it safe
until it turns out that it makes you
your [ __ ] your ears fall off or
you [ __ ] you start dying you start
developing cancer it's like
oh the data's going to be out there the
problem is is that
science changes all the time it's
promising
not only are we interested in getting
the vaccine getting immunized but you
should too
oh thank you thank you indian stanley do
you think that number is subject to
change al
because everybody really wants this
vaccine to work and you must try the hot
plate special
it reminds me of the [ __ ] 80s cafe
from back to the future too
that's right with reagan you must try
the hot plate special
it was like michael jackson and ronald
reagan it was ronald reagan yeah michael
jackson ronald reagan and then
i would name the ayatollah that future
was so much cooler oh god hell yeah and
how do they think about it
but um yeah man this is this whole thing
is gonna be
pretty [ __ ] scary they're just
they're just gonna force this issue
and i mean i i legit was thinking about
this last night when i was doing my show
like
i i usually don't get very like
full sparky with stuff but we're we are
really at a point where i
start to wonder like we might legit be
at the end here like this is the way
this is the way like every religion and
every sci-fi movie and every work of
fiction has described
what is essentially our end so it's
it's not it's not unreasonable to start
asking the question
like are we at the end like are we at
the beginning of the end
are we heading towards like t1 thousands
and stuff we're getting there i think
we're really i think we're closer i
think we're closer than we think
i'll say that like i'm sure businesses
just want to get back up and running the
way they used to do you think that
they can they can right now did you know
that
by the way [ __ ] this is a secret but
i should write a book about this i'm
gonna do it ted talks
businesses can get back up and running
if
the governor lets them oh i want can i
do a ted talk too but i want to show our
ted talk to be more like a real
traditional ted talk
look if you don't vaccinate your
children we can't have
this talk anyway thank you for coming to
ted talk
if anybody reposts this video i will
copyright you
require employees to get covered
vaccines
so there is talk about that what would
they say about require i'm sorry let me
ask let me listen to that question again
let me hear that again
employees to get covered vaccines will
there be companies that are
going to require employees to get
covered vaccines
so there is talk about that but it could
be pretty complicated
to do so here's the thing it's not
illegal
but there could be a lot of challenges
to it we do know that you know ah
but here's the thing though
she made she first off she made a
statement
that isn't true the it's not illegal
it is if you have a religious objection
to it
then it becomes illegal many times and
we've how many times has it happen
companies cannot force you to go against
your religious beliefs
it's been fought in the supreme court
several times they can't
so te it is actually depending on your
reason for not getting it
it can be illegal i mean if
i would say this if you're if you're
watching this right now if
if you don't currently attend a church
i would recommend you start attending a
church
and by the way and i don't mean like i
don't even mean you got to go
every week or you just just establish
some kind of semi-regular visits to a
church
a presence there and use the religious
exemption
plus just go to church because now it'd
probably be a really good time to maybe
gain a little perspective
this is a scary time running the way
they used to do you think they'll
require
employees to get covered vaccines
so there is talk about that but it could
be pretty complicated to do so here's
the thing it's not
illegal but there could be a lot of
challenges to it we do know that you
know things like the flu shot now
especially for healthcare workers a lot
of places do mandate an annual flu shot
and other shots like the hepatitis b
vaccine and of course for schools and
day cares often
vaccinations are mandated as well but
there are always exemptions for medical
or religious reasons
and especially for a new vaccine medical
and religious reasons see that there's
your issue there seeing like the covet
vaccine there could be more challenges
but employers are talking about either
considering mandating it or at least
making it as easy as possible for their
employees to get a vaccine
perhaps again the the the the
the problem with that is until you also
kind of fall into
hipaa violations which means you don't
have to
you don't have to give any of your
medical information to an employee you
don't have to do that's against the law
like you don't you don't have to give
any of your medical information
to to an employee for them to be able to
for for them to hire you like
how how can you now i don't agree with
this but even with her saying stuff like
oh you know nurses and stuff or medical
care workers need it
i don't agree with it i don't think that
you'd have to take it but i
do i understand the logic behind medical
workers getting a vaccine
i get the logic behind it i don't agree
with it but i get the logic behind it
but we're not talking about that
we're talking about arby's employees
we're talking about
run-of-the-mill well arby's employees
deserve
any pain that comes to them that's a
good point oh god it's so bad
but uh but like but you know what time
like restaurant employees you're talking
about bartenders we're talking about
we're not talking about frontline
workers here i see what you're saying
rice
but i do have a counterpoint you brought
up hipaa laws
and that's adorable but we threw hipaa
laws out the window when we started
doing contact tracing apps
right and when we start like hip-hop
that's it's so funny i like people
there's certain things that people still
will throw in your face and go hey
hipaa laws say i don't have to do hey my
second amendment's right sorry
you know what i mean like this is
hilarious first amendment
right to assemble you tell that to the
people that charlotte's feel like
you're right it's just it makes me laugh
dude
there's no there are no rules there's
only rules for us there's like if you
i'll tell you this if you tell anybody
about my medical stuff
you're breaking the law you'll go to
jail but pfizer can do whatever they
want like
this bunny looking goofy [ __ ] can do
whatever she wants
the media can dox children and
literally the media can openly threaten
you from their verified accounts now
and they don't so i don't really i'm not
really
uh relying on my my god-given
constitutional rights anymore well let's
finish up with bob's money over here
even having them on site if that's
possible down the road definitely new
territory for all of us make terrell dr
vin gupta as always thank you for your
time this morning it's a busy time
race for the vaccine dude i'm not really
you know what i'm
trying to race towards like you know
christmas
a little bit of time off i'm trying to
race towards like
you know 20 21 moving beyond this
trying to trying to maybe there'll be no
great